>>Reto Meier: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and welcome to This
Week in Android Development.
This week in Android developers live Roman,
Nick and Adam will be hosting the first episode
of Android Design and Action live out of our
New York and London studios.
This week's theme is transit apps so they'll
be taking some of the apps that Ian and I
looked at in the app clinic last Friday and
giving them a design makeover.
On Wednesday, we have three Android developer
Office Hours scheduled, starting with our
European friendly broadcast coming out of
our London studio starting at 2 pm British
summer time.
A few hours later at 2 pm Pacific Time, join
hosts Joe Melon and Trevor Johns as they answer
your Android developer questions live.
This week's topic is building Android apps
using the web so make sure you put your questions
in the moderator or join us live via hangout
to participate during the broadcast.
Then on Thursday, Bruno, will be broadcasting
live from Sao Paulo for a Portuguese language
addition of Android Developer Office Hours,
that's at 7 pm Sao Paulo time.
Ian Ni-Lewis and I will be putting stopwatch
and timer apps on the table during the app
clinic on Friday at 1 pm Pacific time.
Our goal is to help developers learn the tips
and tricks that it takes to make a good app
and make it great.
So be sure to use the moderator page linked
here to nominate the stopwatch and timer apps
you would like us to take a look at.
Straight after the app clinic join Dan Galpin
and this week's celebrity hat winner for another
episode of the Friday Games Review.
That's at 2pm Pacific time.
Dan's decided to go freestyle this week so
there's no set theme.
Just use the moderator page and let us know
which games you'd like Dan and his hat to
review this week.
As always you can keep track of what we've
got coming up on Android Developers Live at
Developers.Google.com/live/Android.
And that's got a complete schedule of all
of our upcoming broadcasts as well as links
to all of our previous shows.
Speaking of which, in addition to our regular
Office Hours last week, Ian and I looked at
transit apps, particularly Offi, M-Parking,
QuickMuni, London Underground, STM and the
UK Bus Checker.
And on the Friday Games Review, Dan and Koh
reviewed collectible card games.
Both of these videos are now available for
you to review on YouTube.
In other Android developer news last week,
we now learned that have over 480 million
Android devices activated with another 1.3
million devices being activated every day.
As always, there were many apps launched last
week and some upgrades including an upgrade
from Q&A app Quora, the official US Open app,
Quotes, a new app for tracking your investments
and a new update from note taking app, Catch.
That's all from this week in Android Development.
My name is Reto Meier, thank you for watching.